[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا من استوديوهاتنا في الرياض
مع خالد ننتقل بكم الان الى استوديوهاتنا
في دبي معكم ميسون عزام وهذه التغطيه
المباشره من العربيه للزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا هذا الزلزال الكارثي على
المستوى العالمي بحسب تصريحات الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان طبعا في احدث
الارقام خلف الزلزال 1621 قتيل في سوريا
بينما تتعثر العمليات والاغاثه لنقص
المعدات اما في تركيا فقد خلف الزلزال
3549 قتيل واكثر من 21 الف مصاب بحسب
الرئيس التركي العدد
5349 ولكن الجرحى تعدوا 22 الف نتحدث عن
22 الف وميه وستين وقد قال الرئيس التركي
ان الاعداد مرشحه للازدياد طبعا فضلا هذا
عن تدمير اكثر من خمسه الف مبنى كانت
تركيا شهدت صباح هذا اليوم هزه ارتداديه
جديده بقوه 5.6 درجات وفق المركز الاوروبي
لرصد الزلازل المركز قال ان الهزه سجلت
على عمق كيلومترين من جهته كشف نائب
الرئيس التركي فؤاد اوكتاي ان تركيا شهدت
خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه
311 هز ارتداديه نائب الرئيس التركي اوضح
ان الظروف الجويه الق تجعل مهمه ايصال
المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه صعبه جدا وهذه
التصريحات طبعا تلتها تصريحات للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث فيها عن ان
70 دوله عرضت المساعده على تركيا في
عمليات البحث وتحدث عن الحاجه الماسه
للجميع لكي يتم ارسال عدد من الكرفانات
وايضا الحاويات للمساعده كان هناك مناشده
مباشره للعالم بهذا الاطار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا نور بابا اهو النور فك الباب حكي ايوه
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله يجزيكم الخير يا رب بسم
الله
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من القامشلي مراسل العربيه
جمعه عكاش وايضا معنا موفد العربيه
الى كلمه الرئيس التركي تحدث عن المحصله
النهائيه اذا ما صح التعبير وان كان قد
اشار بانه الاعداد مرشحه اعداد القتلى
والضحايا مرشحه للارتفاع اخر المعلومات
لديك اي جديد
وبالفعل ميسون اردوغان توقع ان يكون هناك
عدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير الاعداد مرشحه
بالفعل للارتفاع وللازدياد اعداد القتلى
واعداد المصابين يعني خلال ساعات ميسون
ارتفع العدد عدد القتلى يعني بحدود الفين
او 2500 قتيله وبالتالي الحصيله حتى
اللحظه وليست النهائيه هي
3,549 قتيلا ونحو 22 او اكثر من 22 الف
مصاب حتى هذه اللحظه وايضا الاعداد مرشحه
للازدياد للازدياد
يعني قال في كلمته بانها بان ما جرى او
هذا الزلزال هو اكبر كارثه يواجهها
تواجهها عالميه قال من حيث ان الوضع نعم
من حيث انت غسان الطقس يبدو سيء جدا
الثلوج تتساقط هل هذا ينطبق على كافه
المناطق وخاصه تلك المتضرره هل لدينا
معلومات
نعم صحيح ميسون وهو من اكبر
والتحديات التي تواجه السلطات التركيه
وفرق الانقاذ في تلك المناطق الجنوبيه
تضررت بشكل كبير ومركز
الزلزال في تلك المناطق الجنوبيه من اكبر
التحديات هو حاله الطقس التي تتعمق
العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب البلاد
وبالتالي هذا يزيد من الامر سوءا سواء على
فرق الانقاذ وعمليات الانقاذ والاجلاء
وعلى المدنيين والمنكوبين في تلك المنطقه
فهم بحاجه ماسه الى مساعدات انسانيه بحاجه
ماسه الى اماكن لوائهم هناك
عشر مدن تم افتتاح فيها مراكز ايواء سواء
في المدارس او في صلاه الرياضيه وحتى
الخيم لكن حاله الطقس هذه تشكل تحدي كبير
وصعوبه كبيره امام المدنيين او امام فرق
الانقاذ لمواصله عمليات الانقاذ ايضا هناك
تحديات اخرى البنيه التحتيه تحديه تعرضت
لضرار كبير في تلك المناطق ميسون وبالتالي
هناك انقطاع الكهربائي وانقطاع في الغاز
وهذا ما يزيد من المعاناه طبعا طبعا هناك
في المناطق نعم
رئيس التركي ذكر وتحدث كبيره وكبيره جدا
بالفعل وخاصه انه الموضوع لا يطال منطقه
واحده عشر مدن متضرره بالزلزال وتعتبر
مناطق كوارث بحسب اردوغان وقد اعلن بهذا
الاطار حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاثه اشهر في
المناطق المتضرره جمعه معلومات المتوفره
لديك ماذا لدينا من قصص راينا البعض القصص
كلها مبكيه ومحزنه ولكن البعض منها في
حاله الانقاذ تعطينا نوع من الامل
بامكانيه ان يكون هناك المزيد من من هم لا
زالوا على قيد الحياه خبرنا بالضبط ميسون
يعني حالات انقاذ الاطفال على وجه التحديد
ان تعطي نوع من بصيص من الامل في ركام
كامل من
الحزن
والفجيعه
يعني حتى الان قوه الدفاع المدني في مناطق
المعارضه اضافه الى يعني الجهات المعنيه
الاخرى في مناطق النظام استطاعت يعني
انقاذ حياه اكثر من 450 شخص على قيمه تحت
الانقاذ عوائل باكملها اطفال نساء رجال
وطاعنون في السن لكن يعني للاسف الشديد
الاعداد الموتى يعني مستمر بالارتفاع ليصل
الى
1625 حتى هذا حتى هذه اللحظه يعني هذا اخر
تحديث مناطق النظام والمعارضه
يتقاسمني اعداد يعني قتل هذا هذه الكارثه
بالتساوي تقريبا ايضا يعني يتقاسمان اعضاء
في في تنسيق فيما بينهم كونوا انه الحاله
هلا صارت انسانيه والكل يتحدث عن هذه
النقطه انه يجب على الانسانيه ان تطغى
بمثل هذه الحالات وطبعا فيما يتعلق
بعمليات الانقاذ لدينا الارقام السلبيه
لدينا الارقام الايجابيه فيما يتعلق بصوره
عامه ما بين تركيا وسوريا ايضا كان هناك
قد جرى انقاذ حوالي ثمانيه الاف شخص جمعه
خبرنا عن التوحد ان كان موجود وخبرنا ان
كان لديك اي معلومات فيما يتعلق على
الحواجز ان كانت ايضا لا زالت نوع من
التحديات
للتنقل ونقل المساعدات وغيرها يعني ميسون
رغم ان هذه الكارثه لم تميز بين موال او
معارض او محايد لكن الفرقاء في المشهد
السياسي السوري حتى الان لم يلتقوا او لم
يصلوا على الاقل على اليه معينه يعني
التعامل مع هذه الازمه بشكل
يعني موحد حتى الان هناك شكوك حول يعني
المساعدات التي ترغب الدول ومنظمات كبرى
في ادخالها الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
واقصد مناطق المعارضه فيما اذا كان النظام
السوري سوف يسمح بمرورها دون ان يقوم
بتغيير وجهتها الى المواقع المتضرره
الواقع تحت تحت ولا اعلم ان كنا نتحدث
الان عن مساعدات تاتينا عن طريق الحدود
التركيه وان كان هذا ممكن او عن طريق مطار
حلب او غيره وهذا يدفعنا للتساؤل عن سهوله
نقل هذه المساعدات من تركيا وانتقل الى
طبعا غسان ليطلعنا عن اي معلومات متوفره
حول هذه النقطه
بالفعل حتى اللحظه يعني كما استمعنا لكلمه
الرئيس التركي رجب اردوغان او على الاقل
حتى قبل هذا الهواء ما اخرج معكم في هذه
الرساله لم ياتي على ذكر موضوع مساعدات
تمر من تركيا الى
الاراضي السوريه او تحدث بشكل كبير ان
هناك ازمه حقيقيه وكبيره وكارثه كبيره
واعلن عشر مدن او عشر في عشر ولايات مناطق
كوارث طبيعيه وكما اعلن بان هذه المناطق
اعلن فيها حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاثه شهور
وهو يعكس حجم الدمار والكارثه الكبيره
التي تعاني منها تركيا والازمه الكبيره
التي تعاني من تركيا وبالتالي تركيز
السلطات التركيه وراس الدوله رجب طيب
اردوغان على الازمه التي تمر فيها
والكارثه التي تمر فيها البلاد سواء من
تقديم المساعدات الداخليه من الجيش او
السلطات وفرق الانقضاء التي تعمل او طلب
المساعده من المجتمع الدولي
يعني عشر او اربعه عشره دوله وصلت قدمت
مساعداته ووسط فرق انقاذ هناك عشرات الدول
ايضا تحدث الرئيس عن مبادرات قدمتها دول
بالمساعده من 67 دوله وبالتالي هو يعني
بحاجه لهذه المساعدات لكن لم يعني لا يوجد
متعاطي مع الملف السوري طبعا كان هناك
اعلان ايضا من قبل الرئيس التركي بتخصيص
اكثر من خمسه مليارات دولار لعمليات
الانقاذ وهنا اعود الى جمعه للحديث عن نقل
المساعدات بحال توفرت هذه المساعدات هل
الطرق صالحه الان ام انها متضرره واين
يمكن ان يكون هناك تحرك وهل بالفعل كما
قال البعض مطار حلب هو الحل ام ماذا
يعني قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال دعيني
اؤكد لك بان مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الواقع
تحت سيطره المعارضه لم يدخل اليها اي شحنه
من المساعدات سواء من الامم المتحده
ومفوضيه سوريا اللاجئين او الهلال
لانه ممنوعين كلها كانت الامم المتحده
تتحدث عنه يعني يعني وجود شحنات من
المساعدات عالقه على الطرف التركي واوعزت
الاسباب الى امور
لوجستيه هناك رغبه بمساعده المناطق
المنكوبه لكن الطقس انقطاع الطرقات كما
يعرف غسان في مناطق التركيه في الولايات
العشر المتضرره تعيق يعني او تؤخر على
الاقل دخول هذه المساعدات الى هذه المناطق
لكن ردا على سؤالك ميسون نعم يعني ليس
هناك حل سوى مطار دمشق الدولي سوى ميناء
موانئ اللاذقيه هذه الموانئ تقع تحت سيطره
النظام لا يوجد اتفاق سياسي بين المعارضه
النظام وبالتالي هذه الاشكاليه ستعرق
الجهود ادخال المساعدات الى المناطق
المنكوبه خاصه في ادلب والارياف الشماليه
والغربيه لحلب كما كما تفضلت مطار حلب
يبقى الحل الافضل في حل لو استطاعت الدول
المانحه والجهات المعنيه ايجاد صيغه تفاهم
مع الطرفين المعارضه ونظام لخلق جسر جوي
لاثقال المساعدات عبر وهو اعتقد الطريقه
الانجح ان تواجد للروس في سوريا عنا تواجد
للايرانيين عندنا ايضا بعيدا عن تركيا
ايضا هناك تواجد للتحالف هل من تحرك
يعني
المساعدات الروسيه اختصرت على بضع عشرات
من الجنود الروسي يوم امس عصرا يعني
لاحظناهم في احياء حلب واحياء اخرى في
اللاذقيه كانوا يشاركون في يعني رفع رفع
الركام لكن لوجستيا القوات الروسيه غير
قادره على تقديم الدعم روسيا اذا قررت ان
تساعد السوريين يعني يمكنها فعل الكثير
ليس فقط النظام وانما ايضا مناطق المعارضه
المتضرره لكن حتى الان لا يوجد اي مساعدات
على الارض دعيني اذكر كي لا يعني الى
التجاوز الامور هناك يعني مساعده من من
العراق طائرتين طائرتين وسلطا من العراق
ايضا طائره وصلت من العراق وصلت الى مطار
دمشق الدولي تحمل 70 طن من المواد
الاغاثيه طائره وصلت من الجزائر تحمل مواد
غياثيه وفريق انقاذ جزائري متخصص وصل الى
مطار حلب اضافه الى طائره من ايران تحمل
مواد ايضا اغاثيه كله ينصب لصالح مناطق
النظام وليس المعارضه اسمح لي انضم الي
الان ابراهيم الادلبي وهو صحفي من على
الحدود السوريه التركيه ابراهيم اهلا بك
بدايه اعطيني صوره عن الوضع على الحدود
التركيه السوريه ان كان فيما يتعلق بنقل
المساعدات يقال بان بعض الشاحنات للمنظمات
الدوليه لا زالت عالقه هناك او فيما يتعلق
حتى ربما اللجوء السوريين الى مناطق ربما
قد تكون اكثر امنا
نعم اهلا وسهلا بالجميع حقيقه على الحدود
السوريه التركيه لليوم اصبحت هي المناطق
الاكثر امانا هاربين من بين الركام باتجاه
الخيام
النازحين بالخيام من وقت سابق فتحوا ابواب
قيامهم بالنسبه للوافدين او النازحين
الجدد من اجل مشاركتهم الدفع ومشاركتهم ما
يملكون من موارد اوليه للاستمرار وتحدي
هذا البرد القارس عنا ارقام عن النازحين
حقيقه لا يمكن الوصول الى ارقام دقيقه او
حتى تقريبيه لان عمليه النزوح هي بشكل
عشوائي كانت تقسم التجمع المدني الذي كان
يخرج من المدن والقرى كان يتجه باتجاه
الشمال السوري قسم اتجه باتجاه المخيمات
العشوائيه وقسم اخر اتجه باتجاه المناطق
التي تم الابلاغ عنها على انها قد تكون او
قد تكون مخدمه بشيء ما مثل العربات او من
اجل الاعتناء داخلها او عربات النقل
والمواصلات العامه التي كانت تستخدم ايضا
تم استخدامها بمرحله امام من اجل ان تكون
مناطق ايوائيه بالنسبه للنازحين من
المتضررين من الزلزال اما على الحدود فكان
هو النصيب الاكبر
للقريبين من الحدود السوريه التركيه
بالاضافه الى صعوبه الوصول التي رافقت
رافقتهم الطرق كانت طرق طينيه كانت صعب
مرور العربات عليها بشكل سليم وخاصه ان
العاصفه المطريه كانت ايضا ما زالت
كان هناك المنظمات الانسانيه التي
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله داخل الاراضي
السوريه كانت قد فتحت جزء من مستودعاتها
والمواد التي كانت تخزنها لايام اخرى
وقامت بتوزيع قسم منها على الوافدين او
الواصلين الى المخيم وقسم اخر تم وضعه
بعربات ونقل باتجاه مناطق اخرى يتمركز
فيها تجمعات مدنيين تم الابلاغ عن تم
الابلاغ عن وجودهم او حاجتهم ماسه في هذه
الاسعافات لهذه العفو المواد الاوليه
للاستمرار وبعض مؤولات الطعام بالحديث عن
الطعام دعيني اتحدث عن افران الخبز الذي
كانت تعمل في وقت سابق منذ ان حدث الزلزال
توقفت عن العمل وقسم كبير منها خرج ايضا
على العمل لا يمكن تامين حل ماده الخبز
بالنسبه لهؤلاء المدنيين الذين فروا من
التجمعات السكنيه او من مراكز المدن
باتجاه العراء ويعانون في القرص في البرد
القارص في محاوله لمعرفه ماذا سيحدث معهم
هل سيعودون الى التجمعات الس
بالحديث عن المستشفيات او النقاط المتنقله
لم يتم انشاء نقاط طبيه متنقله لانه لا
ليس هناك قدره او امكانيه
لخلق هذا الشيء على المستوى الواقعي ماذا
يوجد يوجد مشفى عفرين العسكري مشفع قيراط
ومشفى باب الهوى فيما البقيه هي عباره عن
نقاط طبيه او مستوصفات كانت
تخدم اثناء الحرب اثناء عمليات القصف
المدنيين كانوا يلتجون رسومات يتم تقديم
الاسعافات لهم على مدار السنه الماضيه كان
هناك شبه انقطاع لعمليه التمويل الطبي
بالنسبه للمستشفيات وكنت قد تحدثت في وقت
سابق عن التهديد باغلاق ثمانيه عشر مستشفى
توقفت دعم الطبي عنها من 13 مستشفى استمرت
بالعمل بشكل تطوعي وهذه المستشفيات منتشره
في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا ايضا وصلتها
حالات ولكن بسبب سوء او ظروف وانقطاع لم
نتمكن من تاكيد الارقام والحالات لذلك
الارقام التي نملكها اليوم او المتاكدين
من وفاه
810 اشخاص اضافه الى اكثر من 2200
مدني مصاب بجروح متفاوته تلقى الاسعافات
الاوليه للاسف الارقام مرجحه للزياده وذلك
بسبب استمرار عمليات البحث عن اناجين او
عن متوفين تحت الالقاب طيب طبعا الرئيس
التركي تحدث عن اكثر من خمس مليارات دولار
لعمليات الانقاذ اصداء كلمه الرئيس كيف
كانت
كان الرئيس يتحدث عن المشكله التي حدثت في
منطقه جنوب شرق تركيا او الولايات التي تم
استهدافها والتي تاثرت بقوه الزلزال واعلن
حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاثه اشهر لا يمكن
المقارنه ما بين القدره الهائله التي
تمتلكها تركيا وما تمتلكها السلطه
الموجوده في شمال غرب سوريا فقط مجرد
المقارنه ما بين الخطاب الذي القاه الرئيس
اردوغان منذ قليل واعلان حال الطوارئ
واعداد المتطوعين او حتى الاليات التي
سخرت من اجل انقاذ المدنيين الاتراك في
جنوب شرق تركيا مقارنه
بالادوات البسيطه والاليات التي يستخدمها
المدنيين والدفاع المدني والمتطوعون هناك
فرق شاسع ولكن ما يوحد الطرفين ان هناك
امل لاخراج المدنيين من زاويه اخرى ننتظر
بمرحله ما من الجانب التركي اما المساهمه
باتقان مساعدات تركيه او ايضا المساهمه
بفتح الطرق المغلقه جراء العاصفه الثلجيه
بتركيا من اجل ادخال القافلات الامميه
ولكن كما تحدث مراسلكم منذ قليل والجميع
يتحدث عن انشاء جسر جوي او جسر عسكري جوي
من اجل امداد المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من
سوريا الموضوع هو حرب مع الوقت وسباق قد
تفرق على ثواني اكثر من ذلك ان يبقى احد
على قيد الحياه الوقت حتى تخصيص من قبل
النظام السوري عم نحكي عن 50 مليار ليره
سوريه قد ايه ما بعرف قدي بيطلع هذا
المبلغ ولكن لا يبدو لي وان كان الرقم
مليار كبير لا يبدو لي بالعمله الحقيقيه
وطرحه على الارض بالمبلغ الكافي الشافي في
ظل ما نشهده من كوارث عندي نقطه فيما
يتعلق بالوضع الان
وكلمه منطقه كوارث او عندما نتحدث عن انه
هناك حاله طوارئ لمده ثلاثه اشهر او غيره
وربما تنطبق على الاثنين على كل ابقى معي
سنتحول اولا الى هذا المباشر
وكلمه لوزير التركي واعود اليك
هناك بعض الاستغلال الذين نراه لهذه
البصل ونحن طبعا
سنقوم ما يلزم جراء هذا الاحتكار الذي وصل
وحصل وسنشارك المعلومات اللازمه والمسجله
اللازمه مع
المشاهدين الشعب ايضا نحن الان علينا ان
نتضامن علينا ان نقدم المساعدات نحن
لدينا
وعي في تقديم المساعدات وفي التضامن ولا
يمكن للتجار ان يستغلوا هذه الكارثه
لفرصهم الخاصه
لزياده اموالهم ولزياده الربح الغير عادل
وبالتالي التجاره تعني اخلاق بنفس الوقت
لا يمكننا ان نستغل اي كارثه لمصالح شخصيه
او لمصالح تجاريه لذلك سيكون هناك عقوبات
عاليه جدا ضد هذه
[موسيقى]
الاخبار كانت تنتشر باللغتين العربيه
والتركيه وكانت هي اخبار مضلله عن ايضا
ساهمت للامانه بتعطيل العديد من فرق
الدفاع المدني وايضا من العديد من
المتطوعين لان الفرق الدفاع المدني كانت
قد انشات مراكز من اجل محاوله متابعه
الاكثر تضررا من اجل ارسال الوحدات والفرق
لانتشال المصابين من تحت انقاذ الاحبار
المضلله ساهمت بعدم رؤيه الخريطه بشكل
واضح او المناطق الاكثر او المناطق الاكثر
احتياجا لهذا الامر بس عندي سؤال ابراهيم
ما هي المصادر الموثوقه التي يجب ان يتوجه
اليها الناس حتى لا يقعوا بفخ هذه
المعلومات المضلله ان كان من الجانب
السوري او الجانب التركي والى اي حد هذا
يعكس توجه الناس لهؤلاء بانه هناك نوع من
عدم الثقه ربما من مصداقيه المعلومات التي
تاتي على مستوى رسمي
فقط
اشغل مقطع تسجيل صوتي واحد لكارثه تم
تداولها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
واتساب لانه اسرع من بقيه الوسائل
شيء مرعب جدا ان يقول احد ان هناك شخص اخر
يعمل في سفينه بالبحر وانه سمع خبرا انه
سيكون زلال زلزال في الساعه السابعه مساء
وعيت هذا المقطع الصوتي ينتشر بطريقه
رهيبه جدا ومرعبه لو سمحتي فقط
شلونك حبيبي يلا انا ابن خالتي لمرتي
بشتغل
بالبحر عندهم بواخر
السته نختار
[ضحك]
هذا مثال عن اكثر من مثال اخر ربما انتشر
وبسرعه وهذا يدفعني للتساؤل والعوده الى
النقطه الاساسيه لماذا يلجا الناس الى
هؤلاء اين هي المصادر الحقيقيه او ما في
سيئه
المصادر الحقيقيه هي موجوده هي الجهاد
الرسميه التي ناشطت الجميع بمحاوله
الابتعاد عن الاخبار المضلله والالتزام
بالتعليمات المؤسسات والجهات المسؤوله من
اجل الحفاظ على سلامه الجميع ولكن اليوم
لا يمكن وضع رقابه او متابعه كل ما يحدث
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي خاصه الوسائل
الاسرع لنقل الاسرع لنقل الاخبار
منصات اخباريه عالميه او معروفه يستخدمها
اليوم الكثير من المدنيين في محاوله لنشر
عن عدم معرفه من خلال عمليه تناقل اخبار
خاصه التليجرام اليوم اصبح مساحه واسعه
للاخبار المزيفه تغطي على الاخبار
الحقيقيه لذلك انا اذكر التصريح الاول كان
للحكومه التركيه هو للمدعي العام الاول
بتركيا الذي تحدث وقال ان هناك الكثير من
القنوات المضلله التي تقوم بنشر الاخبار
زائفه وسنقوم بمحاسبتها في وقت سابق قبل
ان يصدر اي تصريح رسمي عن مدى خطر الزلزال
ومدى الكوارث اذا المتابعه الاخبار
الزائفه ادت حقيقه الى الوقوع في الكثير
من الاخطاء على المستوى على مستوى الحاله
التي يعيش اليوم المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
من سببت رعب يعني بالنهايه بس خليني اشير
للعواج
ابراهيم الرئيس المصري يجري اتصال بالاسد
يوجه بتقديم كل المساعدات الممكنه الى
سوريا طبعا في ظل العقوبات الموجوده على
النظام السوري وربما يمكن القول فراغ كرسي
سوريا في الجامعه العربيه هناك هذا الفاصل
ما بين التعاطي مع هذا النظام ومن بين
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه الجزائر قدمت
ايضا العراق قدمت الرئيس المصري نتحدث عن
هذه
المساعدات ولكن الان على المستوى السياسي
ربما هناك الدول تتحرك بدافع الانسانيه
ولكن دعنا نتحدث عن من خذل ربما الشارع
وزير
التجاره التركي تحدث عن
عن تجار ربما استغلوا الوضع الحالي ان كان
في الجانب التركي او حتى في سوريا كيف
يستطيع التجار استغلال الوضع الحالي من هم
او شو هي القطاعات التي يمكن ان تكون
مفتوحه الان على الاستغلال وعلى سرقه
الناس نعم نتحدث عن هؤلاء الاشخاص يطلق
عليهم بالمصطلح العام تجار الحرب هم من
يقومون باخفاء المواد الاوليه بمستودعاتهم
الخاصه من اجل رفع سعرها في اليوم التالي
او في اللحظه التاليه او في مضاربه ماليه
تقوم الدوله باول الجهات المختصه بالشراء
هذه المواد الاوليه من التجار او بالجمله
من اجل توزيعها على المدنين هنا نتحدث عن
المنظمات
التابعه للدوله او المنظمات الانسانيه
الغير حكوميه ايضا التي تقوم باجراء
مناقصات مع تجار يعرقون بتجار جمله او
تجار المواد الاوليه على سبيل المثال او
كما يمكن ان اتصور الموقف الذي حدث الهلال
الاحمر التركي يقوم بشراء المواد الاوليه
ان كان على مستوى البطانيات او على مستوى
المواد الغذائيه الاوليه التي تساهم
بعمليه تخديم المدنيين المتضررين من
الزلزال والمتواجدين في تجمعات سكنيه حتى
اتحدث عن قناني المياه او المياه
الاصطناعيه التي ايضا يتم توزيعها في هكذا
نوع من حالاتها العدد من التجار من من
يلحقون المال و ضعاف النفوس يقومون
باحتكار هذه المواد واخفاها ويبلغون انهم
لا يمتلكون هذه المواد بهذه المرحله ولكن
سيقومون بتامينها باسرع وقت ممكن الجميع
يسابع يسابق الوقت فهم يعرفون يعلمون حق
المعرفه ان المدنيين بحاجه الى هذه
المساعدات الجهه الوسيطه ان كانت حكوميه
او غير حكوميه هي بحاجه لشراءها باي ثمن
كان
المتبرعون الذين يقدمون الاموال المنظمات
المنظمات الانسانيه الحكوميه
طيب يبدو اننا فقط يسرون على شراء تقطع
الصوت ابراهيم
كل هذه الدوافع تجبر ضعاف النفوس على
احتكار هذه المواد من اجل رفع سعرها
واجبار الوسيط على شرائها بالسعر المرتفع
وهنا تكمن المفارقه على المستوى الاقتصادي
بالنسبه للتاجر على المستوى طيب ابراهيم
عندي السؤال فيما يتعلق بما ذكره الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث عن الحاجه
الى كرادانات وحاويات وكانه القضيه لم تعد
الان انتشال الجثث هل يعني ذلك او او
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه على الاقل هل يعني
انه تركيا مكتفيه بما لديها من اليات
واجراءات لاستكمال مثل هذه العمليه ولكن
المشكله الان بمن يريدون ماوى وهل هذا
ايضا ينطبق على سوريا الاحتياجات
والاولويات الان
نعم ببعض الاحيان قد تكون توابع الكارثه
هي اخطر من الكارثه بعين ذاتها نحن نتحدث
او حتى عن ان كان بتركيا او بسوريا هناك
مئات الالاف من المشردين اصبحوا الان بلا
ماوى احياء تهدمت بشكل كامل ان كان على
قاطنيه او من حالفهم الحظ كان خارج او
بعيدا عن مكان التهدم او الانهدام المبنى
اذا نحن نتحدث عن اناس اصبحت بلا ماوى لا
يمكن ان تستمر في الصلاه الرياضيه او
المدارس اعلان تعطيل المدارس من اجل حاجه
المدنيين الذين فقدوا معهم لان يكونوا في
المدارس ايضا لذلك هناك ستكون مشكله في
سوريا وفي تركيا بالنسبه للكرفانات او
بالنسبه لواء المؤقت حتى يتم اما النقل
الى مكان اخر او كسورية ممكن
للاسف تحدث على على هذا ولكن هذا هذه هي
الحقيقه هذا ما سيحدث منذ الصباح الباكر
تحدثنا عن ضروره وجود كرفانات بالنسبه
للاناس الذين اباتوا العراء ولكن تكمن
الاليه اين ستوضع هناك الكثير من العراقيل
لو تحدثنا بشكل واقع ولكن
الكارثه الانسانيه عليها ان تتخطى كافه
الحدود وكافه المعطيات المرسومه او النقاط
او الحجار المرسومه حاليا على الخريطه من
ان المدنيين الان بامس الحاجه الى
الاسعافات الاوليه والمواد الاوليه للتغلب
على بروده الطقس في شمال غرب سوريا
ابراهيم الادلبي صحفي من الحدود السوريه
التركيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه دكتور سمير صالحه اهلا بالدكتور
سمير اسمح لي ان ابدا قبل ان ندخل في
تصريحات الرئيس التركي تصريحات اكايا التي
قال فيها صراحه ان هناك في مشكله كبيره
واخطاء فيما يتعلق بالبناء من 1999 24 سنه
من الكارثه الاكبر الزلزال الاكبر اذا
مصحه التعبير بتركيا لم يتم حتى الان
تعديل هذه الاخطاء من يتحمل المسؤوليه
صحيح موضوع
الرخص
الاعمار دائما كانت في قلب في قلب
النقاشات في داخل التركي ليس النقاشات فقط
في موضوع يعني المسائل الفنيه في هذه
القضايا بل ايضا في البعد السياسي بين
الاطراف الحكم
والمعارضه طبعا يعني بعد الان ايضا نرى
نقاشات متواصله في هذه المساله امام
المشاهد الماساويه التي
نتابعها
برايي انا سيكون هناك تعديل سريع جدا
لقانون الاعمار بعد هذه الساعه مراجعه
جذريه لكل هذه
المسائل لكن في حقيقه ايضا موجوده انه
العديد من الرخصه التي تعطى بعد ان تعطى
يدخل على الخط فيها مساله المخالفات وبعد
ذلك التسويات لذلك انا اظن انه كل هذه
المسائل سيتم مراجعتها
والتشدد في
قوانين
سيد سمير هل المشكله بمعنى اجرائيه ليس
الا ام انه في فساد داخلي بهذا الاطار
لا نعرف لا نعرف تحديدا المساله فيها اكثر
من شق يعني لا اريد اطلاقا ان اركز على
مساله انه في فساد او لا المساله بالنقطه
الاساسيه هي انه في حالات يتم فيها خروج
عن القانون والمواصفات المعتمده وبعد ذلك
يكون هناك عمليات لكن كما قلت لك قبل قليل
هذا الموضوع كان دائما من المواضيع
الحساسه هناك شيء اسمه مخالفات على مستوى
فردي او تجاري ولكن هناك ايضا على مستوى
تخطيط مدن هل دكتور سمير تركيا وخاصه انه
خط الزلزال معروف اذا مصحه تعبير لا نعرف
وقته ولكن نعرف ان باي لحظه حتى في
اسطنبول هل هناك من خطط معينه
بالرسم وتنظيم انتشار هذه المدن
في موضوع اسطنبول في طبعا استعدادات في
العوامل الاخيره
الجميع يستعد على مستوى الاجهزه الرسميه
البلديه المنظمات المجتمع المدني تستعد
باكثر من اتجاه للتحضير
للسيناريو الزلزال اسطنبول وطريقه التعامل
معه وفي ايضا نعم تشدد في خطط الترخيص
للاعمار مراقبه شديده مكثفه نعم هذه
نعرفها في اسطنبول لكن كما قلت لك قبل
قليل يعني لا يوجد يعني خطه واسعه بانه
خرق هذا القانون يعني في حالات فرديه
شخصيه يتم
فيها الخروج عن المواصفات المطلوبه وهذه
النقطه الان التي برايي سيكون فيها
اثارتها بس خلينا نتحدث عن ما حدث منذ
الامس حتى الان تقييمك من خلال متابعتك
والمعلومات نشرت حتى الان بطريقه التعاطي
مع هذه الكارثه
صحيح الان على المستوى يعني الرسمي والخاص
الان في استنفار عام استنفار نعم سياسي
استنفار في القطاع الخاص استنفار في
البلديات
المنظمات المجتمع المدني الان الجميع في
تعبئه عامه وفي دعم خطه فيها ترتيب
الاولويات
يعني
تحديد اماكن الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الانكار
واخراجهم باسرع ما يكون تحت الركام بس
الاستجابه دكتور سمير نفهم ما الذي يحدث
على الارض ولكن من خلال متابعتك الاستجابه
كانت بحجم الكارثه او لا
كيف كان التعاطي هل كانت تعاطي مقبول لانه
هاي بالنسبه لكافه الدول هو درس اين
اخطانا واين اصبنا كان في جهوديه الكل
يعرف انه هذه المنطقه ممكن ان تتعرض
لكارثه وبالتالي هل كان في استعدادات
التعاطي معها وهل التعاطي معها كان سريعا
ام ماذا شو المشكله بالسؤال لو سمحت
اعدادات اذا استفزت بالسؤال الدكتور سمير
بس بدي اعرف شو استفزك بالسؤال انه نحن
الان ما عملنا مساله الرخص الاعمار
والمسائل الفنيه
في هذه المرحله
دكتور سمير انت اذا عندك مشكله ما عليه
اسمحلي اوكتاي هو اللي حكى مش كلامي
بخليك بس هذا مش كلامي كلامكم انتم
عم اقول لك انه مخطئه في طرح مسائل ليس
بين الاولويات الان هذه المسائل طبعا مهمه
اتفق معك انا ما عندي مشكله في نقاش مسائل
من هذا النوع انا عم نرجش معك انه الان
نناقش كيف تسريع عمليه ايصال المساعدات
هذه المساعدات فتح الابواب امام وصول
المساعدات الخارجيه السؤال دكتور وانا
بحدد الزاويه اسمح لي سيد سمير دكتور سمير
انا بحدد الزاويه اللي بدي اطرحها وانا
عندما اتحدث انا انا
احنا طرحنا هذه المواضيع بقى لنا يومين
نحكي عن كيفيه المساعدات وشو المطلوب قبل
قليل كنا نتحدث ان كان عن المساعدات التي
تصل الى سوريا او ما عرضه الرئيس التركي
الى اخره ولكن في مواضيع مختلفه يمكن
الحديث عنها تعتمد على تصريحات رسميه
التصريحات التركيه الرسميه
ركزت على هذه النقطه وبالتالي هو السؤال
تقييمك للحاله بسوريا منطقه النظام ربما
كان في تعاطي الازمه بطريقه
احسن من المناطق المعارضه ماذا عن تركيا
شو المشكله يعني ما في مشكله ابدا تطرح
السؤال اللي بدك اياه وانا بدي اياه ما في
مشكله اطلاقا بس ما بتحاسبيني على اجابتي
اذا بتريدي لما انا بقول لك انه في
اولويات هلا لازم نقبل انه في اولويات نعم
يعني في الان نحن في تركيا عنا الان حاله
انسانيه
باستثنائيه ما حكم تركيا لا بالحكم ولا
بالمعارضه بيسال انه مين اعطى هالتر الرخص
وشو هاي الرخص وين كيف بدنا وقتها والى
هذا القانونيه تاعيتها اللي هتصير اكيد
حتصير لانه نحن كمان عم نتابع المشاهد
والصور والابنيه المنهاره ما فيها اي
مشكله يعني انه ما حيكون فيها مسائله
ومحاسبه لكن انا اللي طرحته رايي كان انه
الان تركيزنا في داخل التركي على المسائل
الثانيه الان بالنسبه لسؤال اللي طرحتي
ترتيب
الاخراج
المحاصرين تحت الركام باسرع ما يكون
وتسهيل وصول المساعدات
ونقل المصابين الجراحه وغير ذلك والدليل
انه السلطه السياسيه رئيس طيب اردوغان قال
انه اعلنا حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاث اشهر
هذا يعني انه في استراتيجيه بعيده المدى
الان في التعامل مع هذا الموضوع في هذه
المناطق المنكوبه تخصيص 100 مليار ليره
تركيه هذا ايضا طرح انه نعم في اهداف بشكل
مبرمج للتعامل مع هذه الازمه ردود الفعل
الدوليه والتعاطي مع المناشده كيف تراها
دكتور
ممتازه ممتازه جدا يعني كل الان العواصم
الدول المؤسسه الاغاثه للمنظمات الاقليميه
والدوليه الى جانب تركيا وسوريا في هذه
المحنه صحيح انه في مواقف سياسيه ايضا
نتابعها في النقاشات في الملف السوري
تحديدا من قبل بعض الدول لكن انا رايي انه
يبدو انه في رغبه
شامله اقليميه دوليه بتسريع وصول
المساعدات
المشاركه في
تخفيف ارتدادات هذه الازمه في تركيا وفي
سوريا مع حدا الان يعني حتى لو كانوا له
علاقات سياسيه متوتره مع سوريا او مع
تركيا بيطرح موضوع في انه شق السياسي او
خلافات سياسيه او غير ذلك يعني
دكتور سمير للتساؤل عن التصريحات الرئيس
التركي اللي لم يتحدث فيها عن سوريا
وامكانيه المساعدات وخاصه في ظل الحديث عن
ان هناك
الحدود التركيه شاحنات للمساعده للجانب
السوري لم تصل الى هناك في اي اطار يمكن
وضعه
يعني انا من خلال متابعتي للمساله اظن انه
السلطات السياسيه فتحت الابواب فتحت
الحدود امام الراغبين بالتوجه حسب
المعلومات اللي عندي على منصات التواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وحسب الانباء التي
نتابعها وتسهيل وصول المساعدات منها
الراغبين داخل الاراضي التركيه حتى عروض
تركيه بانه اذا كان في مساعدات تجد صعوبه
في الوصول الى سوريا الى هذه المناطق في
شمال سوريا فلتركي عبر مطار اضنه جاهزه
لايصال هذه المساعدات الى الجانب السوري
الان في في وحده قدر الان في عنا ازمه كما
قلت لك استثنائيه ما في حدا يعني بيضع
مساله الوضع
المسائل السياسيه قبل هذه
الخطوات
بالطبع الانساني
والاغاثه لذلك راينا انه هذا التحرك
الدولي في مكانه الان
الهد الان هو برايه تسريع اخراج الموجودين
تحت الرجال لماذا اصلي على هذه النقطه
لانه الخبراء قالوا لنا انه في عنا فتره
زمنيه اسمها 72 ساعه يعني ثلاثه ايام الان
نصفه اكثر من نصف هذه المده الزمنيه ينقضي
خلال الفتره المتبقيه كيف سيكون التحرك
براي هذا هو لان التركيز يعني باتجاه
استغلال استفاد استفاده من الفتره الزمنيه
الباقيه لاخراج اكبر عدد
ولكن انت ذكرت نقطه جدا مهمه تتحدث فيها
عن وحده القدر وهذا لا يقتصر فقط على
الجانب التركي والداخل التركي ولكن ايضا
على المحيط ونحن نتحدث عن سوريا ذكرت انه
رصدت بعض المعلومات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تتحدث عن انه في تسهيلات بهذا
الاطار لم نسمعها رسميا ولا حتى اشاره من
قبل الرئيس التركي لما حدث في سوريا كيف
يمكن ان نقرا ذلك
ما فهمت انا شو قصدك بالسؤال معلش
انت قلت وحده القدر الان ما بين
الاتراك في الداخل وبالتالي التركيز على
الجانب الانساني وحده القدر اذا ما تحدثنا
انسانيا الانسانيه تسقط الجنسيه وتسقط
الدين وبالتالي ندخل سوريا في اطار هذه
الماساه الشامله الليله الرئيس التركي
بانها كارثه عالميه ما حصرها فقط بتركيا
هو هي كارثه عالميه وبالتالي السؤال الان
الدور الذي كان مطلوبا او يمكن ان يكون من
قبل الجانب التركي فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي مع
وحده القدر هذه ما بين الجانبين الروسي
انا حدثت قبل قليل حدثت قبل قليل عن
التنسيق الفني الموجود يعني من الداخل
التركي باتجاه شمال سوريا
وانا نحن عندنا كتير مجموعات موجوده قدامي
هون على التليفون كلها بتقول انه الان في
تعبئه وتجيش من قبل
العربيه في المدن التركيه باتجاه تنظيم
عمليه الذهاب الى شمال سوريا
لا تريد التعليق على غياب هذه النقاط من
كلمه الرئيس التركي خلينا نحكي على
الجوانب الانسانيه كونه القضيه مستمره
ومخيفه فيما يتعلق بالهزات الارضيه
والارتدادات الارضيه المتوقعه ايضا
القادمه تركيا تعيش ازمه اقتصاديه
قويه جدا وايضا هناك انتخابات قادمه
وبالتالي السؤال مثل هذه الكارثه والتعاطي
معها هل له ان يؤثر اكثر واكثر ام انه
تتوقع انه الدعم الدولي الذي استمعنا عنه
سيخفف من وطء ذلك على الاقل اقتصاديا ان
لم يكن سياسيا كونك حساس بهذه النقطه
بهالفتره
الان طبعا مش بس انا حساس كل الان باللي
عم يتابعوا هالصور وهالمشاهد
بركزوا على انه مساله التضامن
والدعم هي لها الاولويه الان والدليل انه
العديد من العواصم
امس الى ارسال هذه المساعدات ومحاولات ان
تشارك في عمليه الانقاذ الاهم من كل ذلك
انه انا ما عندي اي حساسيه انه جاوب على
اي سؤال سياسي لكن لما نطرح المسائل
السياسيه براي الشخصي طبعا انت حره تطرح
السؤال اللي بدك اياه طبعا مثل ما قلت لك
بغير وقتها
نناقش مساله انه ليش الرئيس التركي رجع
الطيب اردوغان ما حكي عن الشق السوري لما
بقول لك انا انه الشق السر السوري موجود
دائما بالنسبه لتركيا وفي قلب النقاش
ويعني السياسه التركيه في التعامل مع
مساله شمال سوريا معروفه واضحه
ما فيها نقاش برايي
الواقع الاقتصادي على الشعب التركي وهذا
ايضا يصب في المجال الانساني يعني المجال
الانساني يتشعب منه السياسي الاقتصادي
المجتمعي وغيره وبالتالي خلينا نشوف يعاني
من ازمه اقتصاديه يضاف عليها هذا الزلزال
كيف تتوقع ان يكون التعاطي مع هذا الوضع
يعني انا رايي الشخصي الان من خلال
المتابعه في داخل التركي انه
هذه
الاصطفافات وهذا التوحد الشعبي هو العنصر
الاساسي في باتجاه الخروج من هذه الازمه
لم اسمع يعني انا منذ الامس لا اصوات لا
في المعارضه ولا حتى من جانب المتشددين
بانه
النقاش يعني يذهب باتجاه اخر الاولويه
الان كما قلت لك للتعامل مع موضوع الازمه
وبس ما في غير شيء بتركيا الان يناقش لا
بشكل السياسي ولا بغير ذلك ما بعرف اذا
القي نظره اليوم على الاعلام التركي كله
عم يكتب الاعلام التركي وسائل الاعلام
القنوات التركيه عم تركز كلها على هالمده
هاي لما الرئيس التركي نفسه بيقول انه
البلديات استنفرت وعم ترسل المساعدات الى
هذه المناطق دون اي تمييز على الكلام من
عندي العباره من العباره الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان البلديات المحسوبه على الحكم
المحسوبه على المعارضه الاولويه الان
اتجاه هاي برايي الان تتم عمليه التخطيط
والتنفيذ هل هذه الازمه سيكون لا
ارتداداتها الاقتصاديه على الاقتصاد
التركي بشكل او باخر طبعا سيكون لها كده
ذاتها معقول يكون يعني دمار بهذا الحجم
كارثي بهذا الحجم ما يكون الارتدادات
الاقتصاديه انا برايي انه الامتدادات
الاقتصاديه مهمه لكن مره ثانيه بقول لك
انه
الاعباء الان المسؤوليه الانسانيه
الاخلاقيه هي لها الاولويه وعلى مستوى
الداخلي التركي وعلى مستوى العواصم
الغربيه والاقليميه والعربيه التي الان
تقف الى جانب تركيا وسوريا في هذه المحنه
من اسطنبول الاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور سمير صالحه شكرا جزيلا لك